good morning Millennials I'm sorry I'm
just like so busy uploading my Jackie O
flow presets I finally got the outdoor
pack because I was waiting to get them
for free cuz I'm a cheap [ __ ] and I
gave them to her for free cuz I'm a good
sitting you know just I gotta test my
little guinea pig I find that the I feel
like I'm actually the greatest like
guinea pig for your presets because like
I know nothing about presets and I never
use them so it's like if I like them
everyone should that's true and also
this teens are great goody pigs because
you looked it like you have different
color hair because different skin tone
much success rate and well not today
because I used ten sharp and I'm
actually looking in the show today and
I'm looking like honestly like watch out
Adriana Lima cuz I look [ __ ] tan and
slim oh she's retired and I heard it's
cuz she saw she saw vision grant winter
was coming and it was my fat ass nose
your tan leg
I know umm well what's today's a very
exciting day you know personally because
it's you know I'm gonna get a little
emotional because our snitch it's
graduating from college literally I came
home yesterday and she was like I
finished my paper and I go good you're
done for the semester like Congrats like
happy summer and I was like oh no you're
done for life you're done for life
honestly
having been in college graduated college
and now being an adult in the real world
kind of I have to say there is nothing
better than being done with school
permanently some people like to go to
like extra school some people like
thrive in school some people are good at
writing papers like I was one of those
people who it's like I was the anti
school like I hated school I hated
papers I hate it at all like I would
much rather have all the real life
responsibilities it's like worrying
about how to pay my rent than ever
worrying about having a paper doing it's
like there's equal amounts of worry in a
school paper and pay and and a deadline
for your job yeah but at the end of the
day you do the equal amount of work and
for a school paper it goes nowhere it
means nothing right for a job you know
you're actually contributing to
something in the real world and yeah
that's kind of cool so I'm excited for
Margo I feel like Margo's like me like
she's not the type but she's not gonna
go to secondary school like I just so
she's like all a person there's just no
better feeling than knowing you will
never have homework again like and I've
forgotten about that feeling cuz I've
been out of school for so long now but
like I'm looking back I'm Mara and I'm
so happy for her like how she used to
worry about those paper
like people never have that pit again
there's no better feeling than knowing
that Margot is never gonna talk about
her classwork and selfishly I'm really
looking forward to her never talking
about her power of ethnicity class I
think it's called
I'm just so looking forward to know it's
called race and ethnicity power with
something she's always talking about
it's such an interesting conversation
and you know the capitalism that she
keeps asking about conscious I don't
know I'm sure but I used her computer
yesterday because Jackie and I were just
like being such business women yesterday
like getting Kingstown left and right
and I didn't have a computer but I used
to Margot's and like I opened up like
Firefox or whatever Firefox Chrome she
had so many tabs open like about
capitalistic societies yeah she was
writing about like monopolies and the
government breaking them I oh yeah and
she used the snitch Corp as one of her
main examples where there's nature II
just
they monopolized the snitch industry and
they had to be broken up by the
government this mystery yeah it was sad
but speaking things that aren't said so
but just happening here today at the
morning shows first of all we have maybe
one of our most prestigious recurring
guests and I don't want to say his name
because he's finally laying down but his
name is th EO and if you're watching
live on the stream we have our th EO cam
set up and ready to go he's being such a
good boy but then we also have real-life
guests and ones Jackie is particularly
excited about as my because it justit's
like another step closer to us being
friends with Kim Kardashian and maybe
like her coming on the show but not and
live natin live
o relatively not lived the new show and
er joining us their former wags now they
have their own show which is just like
the glow-up one can only dream of yeah
it is it is a dream I've been obsessing
them since season one of wise like I've
I've rode hard for them and I just can't
wait to talk to them and ask them all
about themselves and then of course find
out how Barbie blank and Cole Swindell
met they're like oh I'm sure you know
what's so interesting I forgot to tell
you is when we were in Vegas for the BB
mas I got my hair done and I found the
girl who did my hair because she did
Barbie blank hair for the BB I may know
for the CMA ACM Awards in Vegas like two
weeks before I'm like well if it's good
enough for Barbie it's gonna never mane
and she was telling me that she was like
in the room with Barbie doing Barbie's
hair like while Co is there she was like
they're so cute like they're hilarious
it was like drinking and no one knew
where they met no I don't think anyone's
cracked the case yet cuz I'm weird where
could the former WWE
a star meat like the very low-key
country singer there I have to series
like one it was a random bbm a type
event where it's like she goes cuz she's
a personality and he goes cuz he's an
artist or they met on like riah oh my
god you know a really good call so we're
gonna get it confirmed today and then we
just have so many other questions but I
mean you guys have questions for them
and I just can't wait to talk their ear
off it's gonna be a family affair but
before that we obviously are here to
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast because
it's 10:35 according to my movement
watch ooh
movement watch are you gonna give it to
snitch for her graduation present
because I just got a movement watch and
I love it in its but that's actually a
great idea it's a great graduation gift
because she needs to be on time for her
next endeavor well for movement here's
what it is you walk into a store you
immediately find exactly what you want
for a watch you try it on it looks great
you're ready to go and then it's like 1
million seven hundred and fifty five
thousand dollars and that's just not
gonna work for me unlike a influencer
freelancer kind of budget so that's why
movement is reach on a post-grad budget
right our friends have movement have you
covered with tons of quality clean and
all-around good looking watches and
accessories that you can actually afford
and order right now from your couch
they're one of the fastest growing watch
companies in the world and as one of the
fastest growing morning shows like we
respect the hell out of them as they do
for us movement watches start at just
$95 - you're guaranteed to find
something you love that won't break your
bank these guys are truly ground-up
entrepreneurs success story and as to
other ground-up entrepreneur success
stories we we appreciate that you can
get 15% off a watch today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
movement dot-com / shows that's MVM
t.com / toast toas tea movement keeps
growing check out their expanding
collection MVM t.com / toasts join the
movement or as I like to say join the
yes movement is if I'm brand for us to
work with because there's just so many
different ways to pronounce it yeah I'm
you know we're all about pronunciation
we are okay so without further ado I
feel I feel ready to launch into the
story okay before I'm sorry I was just
while I'm shelling things over here I
just wanted to tell everyone about my
journey Jean Stewart girl with no job
comp tickets are available lots of shows
are selling out but we're doing a bunch
of fun ones this summer I tried to do it
in like fun vacation spots you know so
Labor Day weekend we're gonna be in
Vegas which is Labor Day weekend and
we're first it's the Sunday so it's like
you don't have to go to work Monday Oh
as planned this all very intentional you
did labor day and day is sounds lit but
we were planning our honeymoons and now
it only gives us five days to go yeah I
know I just couldn't pass up the
opportunity to pursue that it would [ __ ]
up my so we need to bump our honeymoons
yeah I knew that I forgot to tell you
okay let's but you just Honeymoon in
Vegas no we could do both yeah well so I
really I feel like the toasters like
everyone should plan a chesty weekend
like cantos a reunion at in Vegas but
there's tons of other spots on doing
Virginia Beach and Richmond which are
both like vacation destinations for the
summer totally Asbury Park New Jersey
and Lexington Kentucky
this summer Charleston almost sold out
when I saved some seats for Shep don't
worry so yeah I'm just like really
excited for this summer fun I'm going to
like so many American vacation spots
that I've never been to that's exciting
you got to go to Myrtle Beach next I
know you know that was on my there's a
country concert there that looks insane
okay I only want to go so I can say
first week Myrtle Beach where it all
began
do you know that I've been yes I know
fertile Myrtle fair I was quite fertile
in tomorrow I work so I get what Myrtle
Beach was once you went and learned
everything from the older generations
older g'bye not by a generation but you
are of another age
I'm sorry Shady well what I was trying
to say was tickets available at girls no
job back home that's all I was trying to
say no sometimes you know I mince my
words we have so much to get through
today and we keep talking about how much
we have to get through but I also want
to add on top of what we have to get
through Vanderpump arose recap and
Celine Dion carpool karaoke oh my god I
watched last night on my TV because
that's what I do I meet you too yeah I
was gonna make it a story but I was like
there's no way she watched - oh I did
because he just came out it doesn't it
to be a story no but we could talk
nobody's happened at the end but I guess
not right now anyway I love talking
about things like saying we're gonna
talk about them later but we have like
no choice you're just family what's so
funny actually is yesterday you noticed
I was watching an episode talking about
this show and not doing yesterday I was
watching an episode of the morning
breath because I was trying to find this
moment that you and I were talking about
we were laughing so hard and we really
had such an estructure to the show we
had the Fast Five we in the morning rose
like we had all these different segments
that's cause we know Olivia here like to
whip us into shape and now
like a bunch of hooligans just like
running our mouths but I wonder do
people miss the segment's like should we
bring in more like structure I'd like
just like free bowling I love free
balling there I had seen some posts
recently actually that people were
curious about toast movie of the week
which I didn't know was even such a hit
really I thought we were forcing it on
people I thought we were too and it all
really died with the secretary it's
either skit confusion of 2019 yeah we
have toast movie of the week we have
deer toasters and we have no that's it
yeah yeah here's the first story another
woman with a lot on her plate we haven't
gotten the chance to talk about this yet
but I'm excited that today is the day
because Rihanna is launching launching a
high fashion couture line one
high fashion couture line a what good to
catch a good chicken line
under LT Emily Rose would be incredibly
disappointed if she heard how you just
pronounced could you well I know you
were away but you see baby of course I
did and did you see that she outed
herself yes and you know what I
appreciated that toaster for putting
yourself on the line and that's the
thing that's what being a toaster is all
about and that whole saga was the
definition of constructive criticism
yeah people love to tell me that I can't
take constructive criticism and it's
like no I can but like you also calling
me fat like that's not constructed you
know I mean no constructive criticism
and criticism ya know it's like I here's
a perfect example of constructive
criticism like someone once write a
comment I wrote like a feedback that
really resonated with me it was when the
whole Roman Polanski saga of 2017 was
like you guys just like run your mouths
and like you don't know what you're
talking about like you have this
platform like you need to like start
doing your research and you know what
they were right like let's see no Roman
Polanski was a good guy we didn't know
we didn't know however I will say that
we do a lot of research for the show we
are up on all the news we watched every
single TV show however sometimes topics
come up while we're talking that we
don't plan to talk about and then we're
talking about it without having done
research you know yeah but it's like
that's just where the conversation went
and you know what whenever I think of
Roman Polanski I think of my run-in with
Adrien Brody do you know about this uh
yes I do actually I was at a dinner
party seated next to a juror and Brody
and I'm not gonna lie I had no idea who
he was and he was telling me and I was
like what do you do
he's like I'm a painter and I act a
little I'm like oh that's cute
and then I left my go cynics though
we're disguise I was like that's easier
Brady I'm like opinion is but he's like
a Jewish figure I was like embarrassed
that I didn't know he should have said
he's a pianist right that would have
been more helpful but he fully said he
was a painter I'm like look I see some
of your artists should have said I'm the
pianist that would tell you everything
that movie was horrible you know I mean
it was good yeah but like I'm like for
being bad right like Schindler's List
and her great movie horrible I still
have never finished Schindler's List
well it does have like a somewhat happy
ending yeah it does so you should finish
it if you're gonna start up no I know it
was a time I thought they put an episode
of Friends they played it on the bus
while we were on the march of the living
trip and it was like we watched a lot of
movies actually some ones that we're
like not good Holocaust movies and like
Schindler's Oates was the one they chose
to like skimp out on no because you
can't watch a skit should alert list on
a TV on a coach bus it's not that type
of film well we did well there's an
update Brett the headmaster there's an
episode of friends this is so relatable
just yet another example of friends
being the most relatable show on
television where Phoebe realizes she's
like a weird childhood Phoebe she like
grew up like half homeless and she
realized that her mom used to turn off
movies before they ended like sadly so
she didn't know how like any of these
movies ended like Bambi she's like it's
such a great little baby that's funny
yeah it was really funny and so they
make her watch like all the films that
like she grew up as a kid and like she
was it's a dark world out there that is
that's funny okay now I think we could
get into the stories because Rihanna is
debuting her new high-end fashion
clothing line
the pop star rule released her luxury
Fenty collection in partnership with
LVMH later this month and it will not
disappoint this LVMH rich ya know it's a
really big deal that's legit yeah LVMH
is like a conglomerate that owns like
everything we do a Hennessy yeah but
like also a million other things Marc
Jacobs other stuff I don't know speaking
the key magazine Rihanna explained her
vision for the company and how she's
breaking all the worlds in the fashion
industry and gave a first look at some
of the clothes which naturally were
inspired by her own wardrobe quote I
used myself as the muse it's sweatpants
with pearls or a masculine denim jacket
with a corset we haven't told the
publication I feel like we live in a
world where people are embracing every
bit of who they are look at Jayden
Smith's childish gambino they dare you
to tell them not to the collection will
include structured silhouettes strong
shoulders core shift--try and daring
accessories Wow
much like her own Savage
Fenty lingerie line Rihanna's funky
collection will be released in
direct-to-consumer online sales drops
every few weeks there will be no fashion
show according to the star love it in
keeping with her commitment to
inclusivity exclusivity the clothing
will go up to a French size 46 the
equivalent of an American size 14 quote
I'm thick and Kirby right now Rihanna
said and so if I can't wear my own stuff
then I mean that's not gonna work right
that's my [ __ ] [ __ ] right there and
I just have to say all for exclusivity
but I like going up to a size 14 is like
not exactly like groundbreaker high for
high yes that's true that's true
okay 1 2 3 4 what's so funny you said
nice ears at 135 no but like they're
never actually encountered a brand
that's 135 that was like no that's a
yeah they're actually no Sandro is 1 2 3
ok be like Ted Baker's like 1 2 3 4 yes
yeah um what's so funny is everyone
keeps being like when is Rihanna gonna
release music and it's like I'm so in
love with like entrepreneur Rihanna like
I could live without Rihanna music
that's not what I need like I need more
businesses like fenty Beauty here for a
fancy lingerie 50x boom I like I love it
all she's a woman of a business now and
I'm not I'm like my I'm not rushing for
her music I'm gonna be rushing to buy
this size 14 yeah I always could be over
new Rihanna music I'm not gonna lie but
I feel like her catalogue is is so large
and wide-ranging that if I went back to
an old album I could find a new song to
like I can find a song that I've never
heard yeah and then I could pretend like
it's any singles and and and he was like
show my jam anti Oh is it not auntie oh
I don't know like a date a data thing
okay but it's like you're the Antichrist
but I'm anti everything but I bortion oh
that's true right no I just like what
are people anti these days abortion we
were talking about Fendi oh yeah
so she said her next album is gonna be a
reggae do you say Reggae Reggae Reggae
Reggae Reggae Reggae I say reggae but
Ramona Singer says breguet okay and so
it's gonna be like the total opposite of
anti ooh
intersect but anti was such a great era
for her with those thigh high boots
uh-huh missing her concert at Barclays
Center was like one of the many regrets
of my life no and I
I don't know or recall any snapchat
concert that I watched with such
jealousy no it were through the whole
thing other than Ben's snapchats of her
concert from the nosebleed seats yeah I
don't know like how or why Ben got there
without me but that's just devastating
there are a few concerts in my life that
like I can't believe that I went to and
had like the foresight to go to or that
I missed so one of the concerts that I
can't believe like I just went to was
when five seconds of summer
opened up for One Direction like wow
what what am a moment for me I can't
believe I missed the life of Pablo and I
had begged Ben for tickets and I was
like let me just get them he's like no
let me get them for you I'm like okay oh
boy wait for Ben to do something we
don't go and I'm sitting there watching
your [ __ ] Instagram story being like
why am I not there that's like I can't
believe that I went to that concert and
at the time I was doing it like as a
favorite to John's but now it's like a
part of history it was like it never
finished and it was iconic no I know
like so upsetting for me like and I
really like loved that album so that was
one of the moments like what's wrong
with me but like when I went to see
Phillip Phillips open up for John Mayer
that was like something I was excited
for but like I didn't know that I was
seeing like maybe the pinnacle of like
alternative music for the next five
years you know yeah a concert that I
kind of wish I had went to was bangers I
never went to Oh Miley Cyrus yeah why he
was like being nice I have no regrets no
I thought it was I feel like there was
so much like fun stuff happening maybe
but and then read I think that's your
biggest real kind of like 1,000% but
this is what I was saying to Martin when
she was on the tow so he did like a
Taylor Swift in-depth episode it's like
I'm so mad that like so many of the
years where I was a Taylor Swift fan
it's like I wasn't financially
independent it's like if I wanted to go
to a concert when bread was out I was
like [ __ ] 15 it's like I would get to
a beg mom for the money it she said you
expensive this you can't go alone so
then like you need a chaperone you need
a chaperone the other ticket Miley Cyrus
best of both worlds with all of our
family at Nassau Coliseum was like the
biggest deal yeah so it's like I was you
catch mating that big deal for
everything now these days like kids just
go to like whatever concert they wanted
so crazy but like when we were kids like
going to a concert was like the biggest
most expensive deal ever so it's like if
I won two tickets to read like it was
virtually impossible yeah like a while
I'm upset about it like it's not in my
control going to this life of Pablo was
100% my fault yeah I was financially
free and and yet you were yet I still
live in shackles yes by your husband by
Daenerys well speaking of Kanye
wife Burger King and Wendy's Sam
jack-in-the-box after Kim Kardashian
tweets a mysterious complain about the
Burger itching okay you guys this was
really spooky it was weird as hell and I
have a couple figures because Kim
tweeted hey jack-in-the-box didn't even
tag them because they knew she was
because she knew they then was it I have
a serious complaint but I won't fully
put you on blast check your corporate
email inbox or send me a DM with direct
person for my team to contact pronto
then she wrote back like because I guess
everyone was like speculating what was
happening and every fast-food chain was
getting in on like the Twitter drama so
Burger King wrote Jackie Box to the
principal's office Hooters wrote not a
good day to be jack no Wendy's rude but
like so true
and now oh and steak um wrote Kim why
are you going to jack-in-the-box cetera
well now it's like what did she see yes
so she was obviously on location
somewhere
oh she tweeted again she tweeted again
that it wasn't a personal thing or like
an order something she said she thinks
they should be made aware of
yeah I'm just I can't even imagine what
it would be but it sounds serious
it sounds serious she was just out here
putting up so much content yesterday
like in the best way Sunday service
Sunday service I feel like either she
witnessed just to speculate because
that's fun like a bullying incident by
like a manager to you know to a
subsidiary he was subsidiary or like
prejudice maybe a month I don't know if
she'd complain about other customers
because that's not jaqen it would have
to have been behind the counter it would
have to be someone who works for exactly
yes like I'm complaining about a
customer what does it have to do with
jack-in-the-box
yeah or maybe something was going on
with fellow customers and they didn't
step in yes and they should have right
yeah no I I really wonder if we'll find
out it is so spooky like it's what I
kind of like really respect the fact
that she didn't like put this company on
blast like so many people love to do
that like whenever anyone in the world
with a couple followers and a checkmark
feels an injustice on behalf of a brand
they like blow it up so much and it's
like it's not this like you know
cashiers fault they're like something
went amiss you know Nene yeah so I got
kind of respect him for not like totally
blowing it up but the mystery is getting
to me totally maybe not and live now oh
maybe let's ask them yeah and also
speaking of 70s I want to know if
they've ever been say feel like they
have because they're all super
and yes SIA performing Sunday service
like as someone who is so like you know
rooted in my faith which not is not
necessarily the faith of Sunday service
even though like technically it's like
Old Testament book you know Jesus in
this ending wasn't you was it you I just
feel so moved every time I watch
especially SIA like I just love that can
we kind of a really respect talent like
every time they have someone perform at
their birthday party like they would
never have like Meghan Trainor perform
at their birthday you know anything like
they really respect vocal and like
artistic talent they just like really
curate the most talented people around
them and see us one of those people who
I think is one of the most underrated
artists of our generation and I think
she has the most underrated carpool
karaoke of our generation and one of the
most talented voices and I just love her
so I love that they recognize that too
and she wasn't wearing a wig ya know it
was incredible I hope and when that came
on the show back probably six months ago
now he and it was just one Sunday
service and we were like what's going on
at the at the West West estate the what
he's it's like I think he's gonna go on
tour but like I really think he's gonna
put out a Sunday service album and
that's just what I need because I don't
love I mean I love Christian music like
and even more Christian than that like
Christian pop it's just this stuff like
[ __ ] Francesca bad a sulli britt nicole
like song it's all just it's so good so
I would I would just die for this like
that's what we need
I went I so much for a album as I would
for a tour I actually would I mean I
would I would look the torque that's
cute like I was just go I don't even
know what this is but I said this is
what I would do but here's the thing the
thing is if we get an album we will
inevitably get it total totally total
and I think just a tour without an album
it's it's a far far cry so if we have an
album it just means like we're getting
everything it's a dozen album of like
popular songs like by Kanye but I also
like SIA like elastic heart uh-huh like
rewritten as gospel and yeah that's it
that's it no it's sick also I just
wanted to take a minute to wish a happy
birthday to like a number one premium
toaster let's hide it's her birthday
today
she'll be at Kim toast this weekend I
just think I wanted to give her a
platform and wishing her happy birthday
I wish her happy birthday too I can't
believe we're leaving for cam twist in
two days you know I know what are you I
know like what are we packed but
seriously like what
my personal packing list in the toasters
but I haven't in the camcos group but I
haven't packed yet and also be a matter
of like what I can fit but I'm feeling
just wearing like a lot of like I mean
my cam toast merch and sneakers like I'm
not gonna be glam at all open speaking
of Sunday service and merch we released
some cam toast merch just for our
campers that is really heavily inspired
by some of the Sunday service March not
the price but the design and it will be
available for everyone Aptos so stay
tuned for that yeah like no $250 red
shirts don't worry I was actually gonna
wear my sweatshirt yesterday on the show
but then I was like no I have to see it
I was really like I was gonna wear today
but then I realize I have to look like
cute for Marcus graduation I can't show
up in a hoodie tomorrow unfortunately
I'm my own my own merch right actually
why not she's so glad if I really
learned anything from Mauricio Umansky
it's that wearing your own merch can get
you very far that you can show up in
your own merch anywhere yeah like even
to a black-tie wedding right okay next
story is just something that I
personally relate to and I'm loving
because Leonardo DiCaprio plays
Instagram boyfriend for 21 year old
Camilla maroon Leonardo you have to see
these pictures you guys Leonardo
DiCaprio doesn't mind stepping behind
the camera for girlfriend Camilla Marone
the movie star was spotted taking pics
of the 21 year old actress out hot
outside the Hotel du Cap Eden Roc in
Entebbe France where many celebrities
reportedly stay during the Cannes Film
Festival and the paparazzi images
DiCaprio was seen snapping different
angles of Marone using an iPhone as she
poses in a flowing polkadot dress
Marone shared a photo on instagram from
the same day as their impromptu photo
shoot with the caption press stage as I
mean funny this is the most relatable
thing I've ever seen
he is a good boyfriend and like this is
just so hilarious this is my life not
many people know this but I did get to
spend some time with Leo and his
girlfriend and they just have to say
like for all the speculation about them
like they are just like a very normal
nice couple and like they hang out with
her family and like this is just this
didn't surprise me just cuz you know I
know them so well but this is just cute
you know and it's like it's nice to know
that me and this like gorgeous stunning
21 year old model like have something in
common no I wonder if Leo takes good
pics so like does he is he a Ben does it
take blurry you think I don't think she
posted any one of the pics that he took
even though it looks like he's getting
all the angles except in some of the
photos it looked like he was taking it
horizontally like landscape and honestly
I'm
any go to Instagram husband knows that
that's just not a good idea but this is
extra cute because like they obviously
have assistants like it didn't have to
be him taking the photo but we know that
like paparazzi follows them everywhere
they go especially in Ken where it's
like this big movie moment yeah but he's
like he doesn't care he wants to support
her and um I feel supported no totally
also um I also felt supported cuz I was
thinking about Leonardo DiCaprio a lot
this weekend when I was in Israel at
Eurovision and Bar Refaeli was hosting
it and they just find the Ark of Bar
Refaeli is life to be just wildly
interesting you know she made it come
came to America made her money got
famous dating Leonardo DiCaprio and then
went back to her country and just lives
her life and now she's like she could
have been like also like was taxes yeah
but I was talking about Fame eyes like
she had a choice you could be the
fiftieth most famous person in America
or you'd be the number-one most famous
person in Israel and she went for the
number one and honestly I respect the
hell out of that totally okay our next
four stories are like they're like all
one cuz it's all just like Game of
Thrones and so if you turn your stories
speaking of do you see the picture that
she posted a behind the scenes still of
them on set it says the pack survives
and its brand like not wearing pants
he's sitting on his chair let me say the
city can his chair pants list areas like
wearing sunglasses and Sansa has a jewel
oh yes I did see that anytime I see a
picture of bran standing like in real
life I'm like it's American I saw a
comment that literally I didn't put
together for like 30 minutes while I was
just like thinking about the picture I
went to go brush my teeth and then it
was my tea that hit me someone commented
is that a lemon cake flavored pod
because you should love the lemon cake
that is so funny
I wouldn't show it this morning I was
thinking of leaving like a cute comment
and I literally couldn't think of
anything oh maybe I could maybe I can
help you yeah I'm all about like leaving
thirsty comments these days you know
yeah I mean whatever happened to diary
of a fit mom oh I don't know you know
the thing about page like such a fake
celebrity and like I have like four
degrees of separations with so many
celebrities it's like I never want them
to forget that like we're kind of
friendly so like I feel like my
Instagram comments are they're like
cement until the next time I see them
you know what I mean mm-hmm so I just I
need help with this one I don't know if
it will ever get better that'll let me
know I know I know okay well we'll think
about it
in the meantime sophie Turner reveals 24
hours split with Joe Jonas before they
got married
so if we turn it what's vibrating
you didn't know sophie turner and jojo
has called it quits once before their
Las Vegas nuptials quote it was the
worst day of our lives she told the
Sunday Times of London and an interview
for a second we both had cold feet then
24 hours later we're both like nevermind
because they know I love them so
relatable I wonder what it was I wonder
when it was she didn't specify that's so
crazy
hmm I mean you know just so relatable to
get again celebrities they're just like
us they get cofee yeah but it's also
like would you share this yeah I've
shared it we did a patreon episode one's
about relationships that with me and Ben
and I was quite candid about the fact I
broke up yeah and like nobody even gave
a [ __ ] so money never you know I love
and that happens like you see something
you expect the world to turn up like I
just told everyone I hung out with
Leonardo DiCaprio I'm like no one cares
you know like where is my paparazzi you
know don't you expect like you let you
hold something new I expect me to say it
like the world to turn upside down like
nobody gives a [ __ ] no or it's like
you're like you're bleeding out you're
like you know I'm just gonna be like so
open and Rob I don't think no one even
recognizes that what's the point
no I think when you step out at the
studio today there will be paparazzi
waiting I mean that's why I Morgan
stress yeah I put San Tropez moves on my
legs so no you're looking good okay
other Soviet territory her year-old arm
tattoo was a game of Thrones finale
spoiler all along you don't remember I
think we reported about a year ago that
she got a tattoo on her arm with the
wolf that says the pack survives and the
pack does survive I mean it's not really
a spoiler no but I mean because it is
they're saying and it wouldn't have been
if it didn't come true it wouldn't have
been especially would have just been
false but no but it wouldn't have been a
it wouldn't have been a spoiler and it
wouldn't have been false cuz that's it's
like there's is oh it's so yeah so real
she could've wrote winter is coming
right you know it just would have it
tied back but really that was the end
message the lone wolf dies but the pack
survives yeah what was the Lannister one
lions don't know that was just something
Tywin so um oh it's probably interesting
if you go back and read all their like
house phrases like in the first episode
when bran is studying yeah like if they
all ring true that might have been a
clue too yeah they say what Lannister's
saying isn't as well isn't so well known
because they have a bunch of other
things that you think are they're saying
like Lannister's always take their debts
yeah but that's not there
residual more Game of Thrones news Isaac
Hampstead right aka bran thought Game of
Thrones ending was a joke even Isaac hem
said right thought the ending of Game of
Thrones was a joke when I got to the
dragon pit scene in the last episode and
they're like what about bran
I had to get up and pace around the room
the 20-year old actor who plays Sark
told Entertainment Weekly on Sunday
night's Game of Thrones finale his
character was crowned the king of the
six kingdoms and a shocking twist to no
one but the three-eyed raven saw coming
quote i genuinely thought it was a joke
script and that showrunners David
Benioff and Dave Weiss sent to everyone
sent to everyone a script with their own
character ends up on the Iron Throne
guys oh [ __ ] is this actually real I'm
happy he set up the ending though I did
kind of want to die and getting one good
death scene with this floating head or
something that's really funny I everyone
like thought that all the time that like
scripts were jokes well I wonder if they
ever put out a joke script for sure I
wonder what the pay structure is because
like bran wasn't really a main character
but he ends up being the hero so I do
get paid more for that no no I think you
get paid based on like your level of
qualifications to the show and they're
younger right after like Cersei is one
of the highest-paid ones and she was
literally in five scenes this whole
season oh no but any time she's in an
episode she a peach I paid for the last
episode because their dead bodies in it
oh my god mm-hmm oh my that's so crazy
so I think I read somewhere that Jon
Snow Daenerys seriously and maybe Jamie
maybe not Jamie actually we're the
highest-paid on the show and then
there's like a second tier of Sansa
Nietzschean Oh Tyrion is a part of that
top group Maisie that makes sense though
because like they're kids and they just
have less bargaining power as kids and
less experienced like no but it's also
like in terms of characters like the
show could have survived without Sansa
you know what I mean
no I couldn't survive without Jon or
Danny or Cersei but think about like
what they were making when they started
filming so like episode 1 season 1
Cersei was already making more than
Santa you know just this being I can
open older more established actors
really yeah why because like she wasn't
more established I never heard of her
she's just older
no she's more established like it says
like whoever's agent was more fiery yeah
and then our last game of thorns story
before we talk about Vanderpump whirls
and bring out our guests Emilia Clarke
worried Beyonce would hate to interest
after the game of Thrones final season I
saw this after eight seasons as the
mother of dragons Game of Thrones star
Emilia Clarke has a lot of celebrity
fans but the most impressive probably
Beyonce in a New Yorker interview posted
after Sunday night's ease series finale
Clarke revealed that she met Beyonce at
an Oscars party hosted by them as by
jay-z there she was approached by the
host herself who gushed about Daenerys
Targaryen Beyonce however like the rest
of the world was at that point ignorant
about Danny's dark turn quote all I
wanted to scream was please please to
like me even though my character turns
into a mass killing dictator please
still think that I'm representing women
in a really effective this way lol
that's so funny
kill the Beyonce Watchers Game of
Thrones I know I mean I mean she
released her house so like of course
what else deserves you besides watch TV
and she watches her house with Alanna
Game of Thrones is the greatest show on
television so like if you're in the
entertainment industry and her name is
dr. Theodor FEMEN that's another thing
like celebrities are just like us like
we all just were disappointed if I gave
her throne so you know I know but I
still have Danny
Gabey - and I'm glad like she died
swiftly you know yeah I wonder what
Emilia Clarke is gonna do next it's very
interesting to see how like all these
characters actors who were relatively
unknown shot to stardom for this one
particular thing like where it's a Glee
it's like those kids got so mean famous
and then a lot of them like never did
anything ever again so we wonder who's
gonna be the Rachel Berry I'm thinking
it's gonna be sophie Turner she's in her
own movie now Dark Phoenix and it's like
a big box man yeah so I'm just wondering
like who the rising stars are gonna be
like I feel like actually like Peter
Dinklage is like done working Peter
Dinklage was probably the most famous
one to begin in America ya know that's a
good call also I just wanted everyone to
know there's a movie out there that I
once watched it's like a silly little
rom-com that stars sophie Turner Hailee
Steinfeld and dove Cameron what yeah and
I think it's important that like
everyone know about it and watch it I
don't know what it's called it's like a
cute little movie about spies in high
school love just like well I'm looking
forward to seeing all the Game of
Thrones characters like in other TV
shows where they don't have like crooked
yellow teeth because it's really
frustrating I get that they were just
trying to be accurate with the with the
time period but I do wish they would
just laugh some candid
them and get those [ __ ] straightened
out it's true cuz candid is helping
people gain confidence through
accessible and affordable orthodontic
care Canon makes the process is
straightening your teeth convenient and
easy by having the customer take the
process into their own hands even though
the customer is taking the process into
their own hands
Candice network of highly trained
orthodontists review each and every case
and direct the entire aligner plan you
can get straighter and brighter teeth in
an average of six months and it cost
sixty five percent less than braces
Kenan makes clear liners that are sent
directly to your home and customized
specifically for your street your teeth
to straighten them candids treatment
line it's an average of six months and
will literally save you thousands of
dollars compared to other guys you're
one step away from getting straighter
whiter teeth take advantage of canids
risk-free starter-kit guarantee plus
when you use our dedicated link canted
co.com / toast you'll say 50% off on
your starter kit
that's candid koat.com / toast to get
50% off the price of your starter kit
canted cocom / toast candy co really
should have sponsored that and Starbucks
and and poem spring because they were
just littered with products everywhere
yeah um okay Vanderpump rules was the
final reunion last night what a
wonderful episode of television yeah I
was really rethinking that's you know
when an episode of reality television is
good when you're like set in your ways
but you get rethought what were you
rethinking you know what I was kind of
feeling for Kristin and if you think
about it like she's really put up with
like all the idiocy with her friends and
it's like now she's going through
something she might not be handling it
the way that they want to but they're
just like being so mean to her like yeah
and then we care about you that's why
we're being like tough love and it's
like you know just like relax like
Kristen has sat through some of the
dumbest [ __ ] alive and she doesn't yell
at everyone and get mad but they don't
do it the way that she thinks is right
so it's kind of feeling bad for them
just like kind of like leaving her in
the dust and they totally understand
she's like that's why I don't talk to
you guys about this anymore like even
though what they're saying might be
right like sometimes you just don't want
to hear that you know yeah no I
understand that what do you think about
James versus everyone because we talked
about it last week but so much of the
world is like on James's side and thinks
he's being like bullied and gas-lit well
the group doesn't help themselves when
they say awful things because they're
like James is telling evil things like
how can we let him work here he says
that but I forget who was right before
the episode ended last week where they
said something so mean about his fam
written as mama it's like but you're
getting mad at him for saying things
about Raquel for saying things like it's
equal
what I agree even now that I'm realizing
that it was Christine who said the
horrendous thing about his family I will
never forget when James mom said that
Christine deserved to be the baron so
Kristen can say whatever the [ __ ] she
launched now James said that's true I'm
really no one named Ronald they're ISO
so bad at arguing some of them it's like
you they they except for success he's
the only one who like speaks like the
tree or lik clearly but like they just
get so heated and they like even if
they're right they just lose their point
they like forget what they're saying and
here's the thing everyone was so mad at
Kristen for saying mean things about
James's family when literally James
talked about Britney's family and our
insects or yeah and like no one's
bringing that up and it's like it's not
even like James talking about Jax's
family would have been the same as
Kristen talked about James Emily they're
all fighting but to talk about an
innocent person Stanley and James was
like I said that because Jax is talking
about Raquel no that would be Jax
hugging that rock house family I'm so
glad that Andy got involved in that
moment he was like first of all you're
wrong second of all Britney's literally
the nicest person here like stop it you
he was trying to make the comparison
that Jack's talking about Raquel is the
same as him talking about Britney's
family it makes literally no sense but
that's the problem with the show right
now it said it makes no sense and like
we're forcing this group of people to
like engage and have relationships with
this person where they're like so
adamantly like not wanting to have a
relationship with James that it's like
it's a broken formula you don't even
like I wouldn't be shocked if he wasn't
back next season move our tails working
there so it's a trying to push this
still yeah it's like in real life
you know what you don't see eye to eye
to some it doesn't matter who's right
who's wrong you just go your separate
ways like it's such a toxic relationship
but they're forcing them to all be
together and so like of course it's just
gonna keep being like
inhumane and stupid and stupid um the
segment with beau and Stassi was so cute
like so cute they think that the regular
real life stuff is not enough for us
like if I watched a show about beau and
Stassi like moving forward stassi's book
maybe them getting engaged
Kristen moving into a house Jax moving
into a house Tom and Ariana moving into
a house like I would enjoy that that's
just like a show about people that I
like yeah but I feel like they think
it's not enough and they need crazy
drunk of [ __ ] like James you know yeah
there was also like an underlying thing
happening with like drugs in yes yes it
was like a few times they alluded to it
like James taking uppers and alcoholic
i preside over a lot of different things
then they address out of our realm that
said something that they do talk about
like openly because it's not illegal but
it's getting weird and like in so many
of these conversations you see how like
alcohol is ruining relationships
especially like Stassi and the Dark
Passenger Kristen in SOL thing like and
Lala is old like they're the common
denominator is alcohol like if you
didn't drink those things wouldn't
happen yeah and it's it's like
frustrating to watch it happen over and
over again like no one takes
accountability like if James didn't
drink actually James was definitely like
hyped up at the reunion though yeah you
know there there's something going on
there's definitely there's something
going on
I wonder why Katie and Tom haven't
bought a house have they yes or they
have yet everyone they were like one of
the first except for Stassi but he was
probably wait Sassie us who lived in the
nicest apartment where they all [ __ ]
wasn't in there it moved most recently
yeah well yes another season in the tank
also I just want to say like my MVP of
the reunion even though like he
definitely had some like not great
moments Jax Jax like so self-aware so
accountable just really working on being
positive and moving forward and it's
like what he's doing it's like when you
try and become a better person it
doesn't happen overnight you get a
little better and a little you still
make mistakes but you're getting better
and better every day and he really is
like he's still [ __ ] up owning every
single [ __ ] and like trying to be a
better person and like really so nervous
of [ __ ] up know in this house we
stand Jax Taylor ice and Jax Taylor ice
and Jackson Britney and like I'm just I
like far as character development like I
think he is the most developed this
season he's moved the needle and like I
was feeling scheana and that's what I
was gonna say I was rethinking
everything also cuz she was just like
not seeing yourself she's seriously
finally just like relaxing having a
normal conversation with Lola instead of
like blowing something up she was just
like I feel like you like the other
girls better than me and like I miss you
and Lala was like I don't I will work on
it like that I'm adults handle
conversations scheana was the only
person at the whole reunion who could
get Lila to apologize it to make she was
wrong Yeah right that speaks to Sheena's
heart heart and like I I'm gonna really
matter I saw some comments people are
really mad at me because I'm like
continuing to defend Lola and like I
would blindly defend her but I don't
even think I'm being blind about it like
nothing that she did to me in these
reunions is wrong because she literally
didn't talk this episode no but like
last week when she like lit
at everyone like yeah I was totally fine
with that like everyone went below the
belt and she comes back swinging and
just because she's better at fighting
like then that she crosses a line like
they all cross lines yeah sorry that she
wants well anything else you want to
discuss before we put this season event
of our pearls to bed no but apparently
we both have the worst judge of
character it's laughable according to
according to em about
oh well that's brings me back to my
previous point that's not constructive
criticism like I'll get read it to me
again
okay well first there was when you have
the worst judge of character it's
laughable the previous comment was you
guys are insane - Stan Jackson Britney
so that's my be avenged
okay so here's let me just look quickly
like describe so you both have the worst
judge of character it's laughable
obviously that's not constructive
criticism I would say that's bullying
almost so if we wanted to turn this
sentence into a constructive criticism I
would say I think you guys are wrong
about jack side
I mean I dare you to reconsider take a
look at these three examples maybe your
judgment is off yeah but speaking of
anyways I love the show by speaking of
criticism and constructive criticism we
are doing a patreon episode by the end
of this month yeah called mean tweets we
are reading mean comments mean posts
mean podcast reviews about I'm so scared
I'm scared I'm excited I'm looking
forward to getting some constructive
criticism because I always try and keep
up with their views but there's like a
lot of very fine that we're gonna source
the comments on our own so don't feel
like you have to comment us right now
with like a lot of mean comments and
we're good don't we have years worth of
comments and reddit threads don't you
worry I'm so excited I actually I'm
nervous it's gonna give me such a pip
but you know actually I'm gonna leave it
to you to source because I really can't
like go through every I like I it it
really said weighs heavy on your
additive I I really am yeah yeah and I'm
less sensitive so I will I will take the
helm and I'm excited because um it's
gonna be crazy anyways we're gonna bring
on that and Lynn will take a quick
minute break go get a snack go go to the
bathroom leave a comment on the YouTube
treatment you have one for not and live
about their new show on e and we will be
back momentarily bang
you
we are back with NAT and Liv but more
importantly they brought their dog and
Theo's here today and it's just it's
honestly the happiest day the studio's
ever seen and they're like being so
[ __ ] cute and you can really teach us
about how to get along with others but
try not to be distracted by their
cuteness welcome that and live thank you
guys so much for being here we are so
excited to have you I've been a Stan
since day one why and the fact that you
guys have your own show now is just like
the dream Oh sense this room yeah how
did that process come about wow it was
kind of a natural progression for us
being on Way and our family we and
Olivia actually put on a vision board
like 10 years ago we wanted to have her
own TV show that's so funny yeah and
then they just approached us after wigs
and it was kind of a no-brainer fresh
yeah when you found out wags was ending
did you know the show was coming in the
pipeline or were you like sad about it
we've been thinking about it and stuff
because that was our goal but another
timeline we knew it was happening
because we just were gonna make it out
it wasn't nothing happening yeah yeah
we've been trying that here it's like
really wow your show is with your
extended family the two of your cousins
so your siblings your sisters on the
show and your brothers yeah and every
why I'm up in Canada so what's it like
working with your family I mean we
highly recommend yeah yeah no we love it
I mean I think everyone is funnier than
us to be honest if people like think
we're crazy and fun we think we're kind
of the tame ones yeah
so just to be with them that long period
of time was amazing
so it's the whole season filmed when
you're in Canada or is it also in LA
there's a little bit in LA like one
episode okay cool you guys live full
time in LA yeah so we don't really go
back to Canada a whole lot so it's fun
to go back and do like some like
down-home stuff like we milk some goat
oh shut up oh my god what is she what is
the technique when milking you know
[Music]
just grab pull crap like a pinching
thing who's the better goat milk are out
of the two of you that's so cute so
we've also seen you guys recently on
Kardashians yes yes Friends of Kim K and
we're just like loving watching you're
jealous
beautiful glam women yeah I do meet her
we love to speculate about how yeah yeah
so one of our really good friends Ariel
who's a makeup artist lived with us when
he first moved to LA from New York and
then he worked for Kim and Kylie and we
met through him so he introduced us it's
don't you take care here yeah that's it
is it looks so much fun like we're
Jewish and we want to go like no just
think it's like an experience yeah one
should have such good energy yeah such
good energy oh speaking of great energy
this is my Segway because we got so many
great cast members from yeah yeah it's
but mostly the ones that you're friends
with Nicole and are you still close with
Barbie we're not super close I don't see
her that often but yeah we're still good
friends oh so she's not dating country
star Cole Swindell oh yeah and we ship
it
we just we can't figure out like where
would the two of them be in the same
place to be honest we haven't talked to
her about her former WWE and reality
star like where do the two OH
what I just I see in the vent I just
don't see it you know I know but I guess
they'd hot um how are you guys single
yes
no no no are you still would you still
qualify for wags in your new
relationship possibly oh good I
shouldn't even be not trying to get too
personal with outside
thank you so the show premieres June 2nd
Ani yes this is nervous at all cuz you
know when you're a part of like a show
like wags there's other people for
people to between up things at but this
is your show and your min tweets yeah
how are you nervous about like being
vulnerable opening your family up to
that no because it is all you're
surrounded by your family and I don't
really care you know like you said other
customers we don't know they could say
things and do things yeah you don't care
if my brother or sister calls you this
or that you know and then I think
they're pretty great so I'm not like in
Ferris I'm hoping people like take to us
and like us well everyone loved you from
mines you guys were just like you're you
know the breakout stars thank you
so I think at all is lining up to be
great and you're taking the busy to
night time sod which means I'm getting
my Sunday nights back which I'm really
excited about a night honey getting
better than ever are you guys excited
you guys watch any other shows on you
guys watch Kardashians actually don't
watch any I watched Kardashians
you support your friends take your
family members like take convincing to
like join you on TV or work they like
naturally kind of all about it I mean
our most active a little hesitant and
they were like sure I'll timid and then
the cameras came on all say we're
singing do it the stars yeah so we have
a lot of beauty questions for you okay
you guys are just like media influencers
I love I learned so many makeup tips are
watching you and wise and like hairs hi
buns hi ponies like under eye
brightening I used to like literally put
bronzer under my eyes until I saw you
boy
killer seriously though and then I
started watching tutorials so like I
just want to thank you for that so what
goes into like your daily routine like
facials
what you guys did a lot of like vaginal
steaming on the show so what do you
actually keep up with like what are some
things that you recommend we're moving
back to the veg team no but
yeah yeah solution we stopped facials
like lace officials I go try to go up
once every like three weeks
Wow I know it's it's kind of a lot and
then what's the one you just got the
pure Ganesha yeah like where they like
use the micro needling and they like
kind of do a little pricks on your face
they pull your blood and spin it and get
the PRP and put it back in - oh please
do you look for how long it's not that
bad
just a few days to kind of like peel a
little Freddy cougar ish so like glowy
and dewy yeah it's okay so what are some
like beauty things that are just a total
crock totally the cryotherapy oh yeah I
have you guys done cryotherapy no I
haven't I've wanted to you think I'm not
gonna do it because I heard some girl
died in there oh yes okay it was like
she works in it [ __ ] works out she
locked herself in for the night and she
literally died cuz she couldn't get out
so now I'm just thinking like oh man I
would never be able to get out I would
serve over me no eat you it's just like
not my thing also why no I'm good you
know cold yeah I don't know you lay in
the Sun we stopped you did we stop we
went for one more run in the tanning bed
yeah you two going okay we got gold
catches of its kind of that yeah that's
like the mud the hardest part great in
yes yes spray it's like if we were to
actually eventually go on vacation I'm
definitely gonna I want to live you know
yeah music are we supposed to know your
life exactly how does my culture do it
yeah yeah well I've learnt you tune in
June 2nd on a NAT relatively not and
lives such a cute name by the way
and thank you guys for being here
following up with you guys on Instagram
premium content always being distributed
on their Instagram accounts what are
your Instagram accounts Natalie Halcro
at Olivia Pearson I'm so excited to see
you on our TVs again here we are
thank you guys for being thanks
we will see you tomorrow morning at
10:30 bye hi
you